en vingt ans les engagements politiques
en alimentation ont été nombreux mais
quand il est venu de toutes ces belles
paroles
[Musique]
en vingt ans il a souvent été question
d'améliorer les choses de volonté
politique qui se traduisent en gestes
concrets ou pas
[Musique]
trouvez vous que beaucoup d'allemands
qui contiennent des gras trans l'équipe
de l'épicerie a passé les allées du
supermarché halal ou afin de dénicher
tous les produits qui en contiennent
la situation est si grave qu'en 2005 le
gouvernement fédéral s'attaque à ces
mauvais gras il suggère à l'industrie
alimentaire des quantités à ne pas
dépasser
après avoir longtemps privilégié la
proche volontaire le canada bons
derniers de classe va en 2018 après les
états unis et l'union européenne
interdire les gras trans
la même année il propose de modifier
l'emballage des produits pour mettre en
lumière les quantités de sucre de sodium
et de gras saturés nous proposons
aujourd'hui l'affichage dans ses apports
nutritionnels sur les devants de
l'emballage dès qu'un produit dépasse
quand un taux de 15 % de l'apport
quotidien dans l'une ou l'autre des
trois catégories on verra apparaître un
de ses symboles
l'industrie a eu quatre heures pour
reformuler ses produits avant la mise en
place de l'affichage modifie qui lui
devrait apparaître sur les emballages à
compter de décembre prochain
on conseille aux adultes de boire deux
tasses de l'hébergeur et trois tasses
aux personnes de 50 ans et après une
longue attente on dépoussière la version
du guide alimentaire canadien de 2007
pour tracer la route vers une saine
alimentation dans les versions
précédentes
on parlait de portions alors que le
nouveau guide part plutôt de proportion
contre toute attente le gouvernement a
réussi à se tenir à une saine distance
des différents lobbys le nouveau guide
alimentaire nous suggère donc de
consommer plus de protéines végétales
moins de viande rouge de remplacer les
boissons sucrées et les jupes hardelot
et il place les produits laitiers dans
la catégorie des protéines
onze écoles sur 15 offre aux élèves sous
une forme ou une autre de la malbouffe
malbouffe qui se déguise parfois en
nourriture santé
d'ailleurs de nouvelles politiques
seront prochainement instauré pour
sortir la malbouffe des écoles afin
d'encourager les élèves faire de
meilleurs choix
avec le dépôt la même année que notre
reportage de la politique pour un virage
santé à l'école on constate la
diminution importante de la place
consacrée aux aliments à faible valeur
nutritive
mais beaucoup de travail reste à faire
puisque la malbouffe est encore présente
autour des écoles dans les arénas et
d'autres lieux fréquentés par les jeunes
[Musique]
dans l'épicerie si on veut savoir ce que
contient un produit on regarde la liste
d'ingrédients et le tableau de la valeur
nutritive au restaurant bonnes choses on
a débattu à ottawa en 2006 un projet de
loi obligeant les restaurants à inscrire
et sur les menus la quantité de calories
de gras et de sodium le public exigeant
et j'étais à jean yves à voir ça comme
un droit national et au québec qui n'est
pas au mouvement donné les gens des
formations qui le projet de loi est
battu ayant rencontré une forte
opposition de l'association canadienne
des restaurateurs qui prétendent entre
autres qu'il n'y a pas d'espoir sur les
menus pour mettre l'information
nutritionnelle
nous avions à l'époque je refais le menu
de saint-hubert choisi ça prendrait plus
jeunes page additionnel juste le médecin
dans les menus puis tout ça pour ces
permis de refaire votre menu z'amis des
valeurs nutritionnelles sur une table
c'est avec est ce que c'est bien ça
toujours rien sur les menus saint-hubert
par contre chez mcdonald's de subway tim
hortons et d'autres grandes chaînes de
restauration rapide on affiche au
minimum le total de calories sur les
menus
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps aussi qu'on parle de
la piètre qualité de la nourriture
servie aux résidents de centres
d'hébergement et de soins de longue
durée si on vient les budgets qui sont
offerts au québec pour l'alimentation
qui sont aussi famélique quant à moi je
peux sûrement que ce qu'on offre aux
personnes lui ont permis de combler
leurs besoins dans plusieurs centres en
2010 le budget était de 1 dollar à 66
par pas par résident centres
d'hébergement douze ans plus tard il est
de 2 $ 14 une augmentation de 48 cents
pendant ce temps de grands centres
hospitaliers cherche malgré tout à
augmenter la qualité de la nourriture
servie aux patients
[Musique]
nous avons eu la commande de l'opérateur
menu harmonie si puisqu'on a fait un
rythme assez accéléré on jette et 25%
des plateaux
donc il ya 25% des plateaux qui revenait
à la cuisine on les met à la poubelle
les plateaux est à jeter parce que papy
de sympa bon froid servi au mauvais
moment bien sûr tout n'est pas parfait
mais les efforts sont là pour faire en
sorte que le séjour soit plus agréable
on essaie d'avoir de plus en plus le
pouls de la clientèle nous sommes
vraiment excellent côté services à la
carte du tout c'est surprenant pour une
oqtf
les enfants ont besoin d'un certain
nombre de nutriments pour bien se
développer le plan ne fait pas partie de
susi qu'en est-il de la qualité de l'eau
que nos enfants boivent pendant qu'un
matériau on a testé lot de dix mille
écoles et cpe au québec dans une ville
de la grosseur de montréal l'eau d'une à
deux écoles sera testé chaque année
l'épicerie a testé les fontaines de 15
points d'eau dans les écoles primaires
du québec dans près de 30 % des cas la
quantité de plomb était supérieur à la
norme canadienne permise de 10
microgrammes de plomb par litre d'eau
malgré notre dénonciation de la quantité
de plomb contenu dans l'eau des
fontaines dans les écoles en 2013 il a
fallu attendre huit ans pour que le
gouvernement s'attaque au problème
résultat on a changé ou condamner plus
du tiers des robinets et des fontaines
du réseau scolaire
[Musique]
contrairement au reste du canada au
québec la loi ne permet pas de publicité
pour les enfants à la télévision depuis
1981 pourtant ils n'ont jamais été
autant bombarder de messages de toutes
sortes tout ce qui est emballages
étalage présentoirs sont des exclusions
de la loi par conséquent nos épiceries
sont remplies de publicité qui sont
destinés aux enfants il faut beaucoup
beaucoup de politiques mais si on fait
des changements par rapport au mcee des
animateurs ça va avoir un impact sur
l'environnement nutritionnelle dans
lesquels nos enfants c'est sont en train
de grandir un projet de loi fédérale
visant l'étiquetage et l'emballage des
produits destinés aux enfants été
déposée il ya cinq ans mais on attend
toujours sa mise en place
[Musique]
on aurait pu parler aussi
d'environnement d'utilisation de
pesticides de gaspillage alimentaire
d'accès de la nourriture de qualité pour
tous autant de chantiers que l'épicerie
surveillera pour vous dans les 20
prochaines années